first up he is the senior senator from
Vermont he didn't quite make it to the
nomination but in my lifetime I have
never seen a candidate as beloved as
Bernie Sanders
well Bernie you can see why you weren't
the nominee they hate you we always have
to allow a little more extra time when
bernie is on just for applause but I
want to ask you Bernie how do you write
the convention now that it's over well I
think it was a good convention I think
it brought together people with
different points of view within the
Democratic Party are the progressives
the more conservatives the moderates but
I think what comes out of that
convention bill is the understanding
that Donald Trump is the most dangerous
presidential candidate in the modern
history of this country and that he must
and I say that I say that bill not just
because of his absurd views on so many
issues you know he believes that climate
change is a is a hoax he wants to give
hundreds of billions of dollars in tax
breaks to the top 1% but above and
beyond all of that this guy is running
his entire campaign based on bigotry
based on trying to divide us up based on
trying to insult Mexicans and Latinos
and and Muslims and women and
african-americans remember that this guy
was one of the leaders of the so-called
birther movement which try to deal Ajith
amis the first african-american
president that we have ever had so this
is a guy who is dangerous who does not I
think that Muslim father of the young
man who died in Iraq was absolutely
right that somebody like Trump does not
understand the Constitution of the
United States I think you see many
Republicans who believe that as well so
this is a guy who must be defeated ah
it's no secret bill that Hillary Clinton
and I have disagreements on a number of
issues and what I intend to do the day
after Hillary Clinton is elected
president of the United States is to do
everything I can to make sure that she
goes forward as progressively as she can
maintaining the very strong Democrat
progressive platform or that we passed
together
well and I must say unlike some of your
supporters I think that's why you are a
great Patriot because you wrote it
brought it right back to the central
issue we have to defeat Donald Trump you
are a warrior sir and the hardest thing
for a warrior to do is to fall on his
sword but you did you have come in line
with the idea that we have just two
choices and you know I think of Al Gore
after the 2000 election when the Supreme
Court made that decision Donald Trump
would have went didn't go wouldn't have
gone away quietly Al Gore did the
patriotic thing and you are doing the
patriotic thing but it's like us it's
not just I think the right thing to do
for the moment I think what we have got
to do and I said this as best I could in
Philadelphia is it we must continue the
political revolution we must continue to
bring millions of people into the
political process to stand up to take on
the billionaire class to fight for
economic and social and racial and
environmental justice and that fight
must continue the day after the election
because fundamental changes
transformational changes bill take time
to happen they don't happen overnight
and that movement has got to continue
and what we are doing by the way is
converting our movement from a
presidential campaign to a movement that
tries to activate the American people
and get young people to start running
for office for school board and City
Council and state legislation that is a
continued
politically all right well let me follow
up on a couple of things you said you
said the movement should continue
you mentioned young people I was on with
Chris Matthews a couple of weeks ago we
were talking about you and the
assumption from him was that you could
not run again because you're 74 and I
said Chris you're 70 I'm 60 if anybody
should not be ageist it's us i I must I
must push back against this idea that
people in their 70s are at the end and
that you've just dribbling down to the
last few days of your life people treat
their bodies differently as they go
through life they are very different in
their alertness in their health and and
there is no reason why you can't run
again
from what I see what do you think of
that bill I mean thank you very much but
it is one year from now is a long time
off from now my term ends in two years
as a US senator from Vermont everything
being equal I intend to run for
reelection from Vermont a state that I
love very very much but what I will tell
you is whatever my political future may
or may not be I will be fighting as hard
as I can to stand up for a declining
middle class to take on the grotesque
levels of income and wealth inequality
that we're seeing right now to demand
that the United States join the rest of
the industrialized world and guarantee
healthcare to all people as a right to
make public colleges and universities in
this country tuition free those are
issues that we have got to continue the
fight for okay I didn't hear the end of
that yes people are always applauding
you but I think I get the gist all right
so you know people were talking today a
lot about the fact that at the
convention last night when
when Hillary mentioned you and the night
before when Obama gave you a shout-out
you didn't look too happy you know you
kind of didn't crack a smile he looked
like a husband to his sitting there in
the waiting room you know what
well the wife tries on the clothes I
mean outside the waiting room not in the
waiting room but but the other moment I
saw at the convention which was the
opposite when your brother came on the
stage no I when I was talking about you
all year I always said Bernie Sanders is
giving us a new deal that is the only
phrase that comes to mind he's saying
look you pay a little more in taxes but
look at what you get like more like a
European democracy and your brother
invoked the New Deal he talked about
your parents and their love of the New
Deal and how you were carrying on that
tradition and there we did see a lot of
emotion
you were verklempt Bernie come on right
and I got to you my brother reminded me
of this is how my parents who died young
might have felt at that moment and
obviously that was something that was
struck a deep chord in me you know we
grew up in a family didn't have a whole
lot of money my father dropped out of
high school my mother never went to
college I think the idea that her son
might be a serious candidate for
president of the United States is
nothing that a they ever would have
dreamed of so that's what struck a chord
in me okay well like I said Bernie
you're not too old to run again
think about it Bernie Sanders everybody